I have a couple quick announcements
before we get started today
um the first quick announcement is we
use this thing in cs19 called high
resolution course feedback basically
goes like this have you ever been a
class at a mid-corder evaluation
it's too late to change by them but
we're probability people
maybe we don't need to sample everybody
at one point in the quarter so in cs109
we do the slightly more elegant thing
where we're constantly set randomly
sampling students to get some feedback
so we can make the course better and
that means we can adjust immediately we
don't have to wait till like week six or
week seven to make changes so you might
get an email that says something like
please submit Anonymous feedback for
your class uh at the end of the course
we see you complete the survey of course
we see responses but we don't see your
individual responses not connected to uh
your participation
you guys have said some wonderful things
thanks for all the positive feedback on
how cs109 has gone there's also three
things that we want to adjust to give
you motivation to actually respond to
these because we care about what you say
the first one can we have more Virtual
Office hours I brought this up with the
Tas and they're like yeah we in fact
added four brand new office hours and
now there's going to be a total of eight
hours that are going to be Zoom only
because there's some people for whom
coming to a physical app store is really
difficult we have so many office hours
in cs1 I thank you guys to the Tas you
guys are amazing use them the Tas are
there so that you guys can get help if
you need it
some people ask I wish that the secret
code thing was put into the recordings
aha I can do that every day I can say
what is the secret code and today it is
binomial bunny all one word all lower
case y binomial because we have such an
exciting celebratory lecture today and
it's kind of about binomial
distributions uh and then people
mentioned that the internet in Nvidia is
not that good I couldn't just
immediately fix that one but I did start
the process of seeing if we can do the
deeper fix so that more people can
connect to internet at the same time
thank you guys all for your wonderful
feedback
as always you can follow along from the
problem set there's a a place where you
can write in your answers to some
questions that we'll talk about in
today's class uh and also you can mark
your presence
okay oh we have such a fun this is such
a celebratory lesson you guys have
worked so hard and now we can start the
process of putting your hard work into
nice packages so that you can solve
harder and harder problems
you have a couple learning goals for
today when you walk out of today's class
you should be able to recognize and a
binomial random variable when it shows
up in the wild and be able to use it to
solve probability problems and similarly
for this thing called a Bernoulli random
variable and then finally we're going to
be talking about variance and you should
know how to calculate variance for a
random variable so three learning goals
you guys in
okay let's do this
I have a hook for you guys
um and it's the hook is is peer grading
accurate enough you know one of the
things that people have thought about
for scaling online education is to have
peers grade each other you can imagine
it'd be a lot easier for us to grade if
we just had you guys grade each other's
work but does that work
and is it accurate enough to be a
feasible uh mechanism for a course we'll
talk about that by the end of today's
class and you'll probably really have to
understand variants to be able to
understand that discussion
okay we're gonna get there by the end
but we have to go through a few
different steps to get to that point a
little bit of review
in last Friday's class we introduced
this idea of a random variable and a
random variable is the equivalent of a
variable but brought to the world of
probability it's a value which is going
to take on a number but it will do so
with probability we don't know exactly
what number it's going to take on yet
and so we have to think about the
distribution of different values that it
can take on so certainly one of the most
important things about a random variable
is that relationship between the values
it can take on and probability and we
call that the probability Mass function
so if we declare something to be a
random variable we'll often use a
capital letter to distinguish it from
like a non-random variable so why help
welcome to the world why you are a
random variable if that's a random
variable it's not an event you can't ask
what's the probability of Y you need to
ask the probability questions about
events but if you ask any
you know any less than equal to not
equal to question on why you will end up
with an event so this is the same as
saying the event that y takes on the
value to so why it's going to take on
value probabilistically we now have an
event which means we can now uh ask a
probability question similarly y less
than three also an event
if you ask the probability of an event
you will get a number between zero and
one and that all leads to this
interesting but sometimes confusing at
first conclusion that this is a function
this is a function where you're putting
in different values and it's returning
you the probability that your random
variable takes on that value and this is
the be all end-all of random variables
if somebody gives you this thing called
the probability Mass function which
relates the different values you random
variable can take on to its different
probabilities thank you person you've
just made our life very simple now any
probability question involving this
random variable will be straightforward
a little bit of Ruby
random variables why are they such a big
deal it just feels like no notation and
the reason there's such a big deal is
because it gives other people a
mechanism to provide you with this
probability Mass function and if
somebody gives you a probability Mass
one they've done a whole bunch of work
for you thank you person who did a lot
of work for me we can now use all that
work in our Downstream probability tasks
a probability Mass function that
relationship between the value random
variable can take on and its probability
can be expressed as an equation it can
be expressed as a graph it can be
expressed as code lots of ways that
somebody can communicate this
relationship between values a random
variable can take on and probabilities
okay so Random variables there's a whole
bunch of things that we're going to want
to know about random variables today
we're going to cover this spectrum every
random has a semantic meaning the most
important thing is the probability Mass
function and then we already know about
this thing called expectation that's a
summary statistic of your random
variable where you boil down all of its
interestingness into one number
hopefully a number that best captures
the random variable
expectation we defined as this is kind
of like the weighted average over all
the values the random variable can take
on so for every value of the random
variable can take on you multiply the
value by its probability and that kind
of gives you a weighted Center of mass
of your random variable
this is a summing loop as you guys
already know a lot of review
three things that made expectations so
interesting was linearity expectations
sum a sum of expectations and this rule
of unconscious statistician we stated
these two in a little bit of depth and
we said we're going to hold off on that
one until further in the class which is
going to be today today we're going to
go deeper in unconscious past decision
but not quite yet
it's worth talking about expectation to
give you the idea of exploitation of a
sum if you have a bunch of data
and you want to calculate the
expectation of this data how would you
do that there's no wrong answer to this
well there is a right answer to this but
I just mean this as an exploratory
question I haven't told you how to do
this already but you guys want to take a
moment and just like get those cobwebs
out and get thinking probability talk to
the person next to you think about how
would I calculate expectation if
somebody just gave me a data set
what
we have the definition for expectation
right there wouldn't you oh how'd you do
that think about it with the person next
to you for just a second and we'll talk
about it all together
just a warm-up
we haven't told you how to do it but
anyone have a guess I love guessing I
feel like guessing is one way of
exploring what you don't know as well
yes an idea over here
yeah you could just take the average it
turns out that's exactly right but why
why is that the right answer
if you were to calculate like accent p
of X for each thing is like the
probability of each thing happening is
one over the total number of things
deterioration of exactly that idea
um so that is right it turns out you
just take the average of all your
numbers that is what the expectation is
that's why some people think about it as
the weighted average
um and here's why that's legitimate
thing to do
for every probably x equals X
using the original definition of
probability we have that limit
definition of probability that's about
equal to how many times does X take on
that particular value divided by how
many experiments were there so if Little
X is 3 or 10 you're going to say how
many times did 10 show up
divided by n
but that 1 over n you know it just gets
pulled out here and this sum over x x
times the count of how many times x
shows up is the same as just saying
let's sum over each of the values and
count them once and so long story short
if you want to know expectation from
data set it's just your average of the
values like you could just sum them all
up and divide by n and that would give
you expectation
and this uses a little bit of
interesting notation certainly if that
didn't just pop out uh something worth
checking out a little bit more in depth
that does give me a nice way to talk
expectation of some sum of expectations
like let's say this is X and this is y
and we have a bunch of data on X and Y
for we could just create a third column
which is the sum of X and Y and it turns
out that no matter how X and Y is
related the expectation of x if you
calculate that number take that average
if you take the average of this column
if you add them together it's the same
as taking the average of this last
column and it doesn't matter how X and Y
are related no matter what this law
always holds
linearity of expectation you know if you
take a random variable and multiply it
you kind of like elongate it's probably
Mass function if you add four you kind
of shift it's probably Mass function and
no matter how you manipulate a random
variable if it's a linear manipulation
expectation Still Remains easy to
calculate
okay but is expectation enough
no expectations not enough it's not
complete information you know
expectation is just taking a whole
random variable bearing it summarizing
in one number like the average of your
values is not complete information
it's just the average of your values the
probability Mass function that's your
complete information
okay that's the end of review it's been
a weekend I hope you guys are caught up
questions
information to reconstruct the pmf yeah
so we're going to get into more moments
today moments is a fancy word for like
higher order summary statistics uh if
you had I mean there's infinitely large
moments so we can talk about that after
class it's an interesting question
yes when we take the average do we just
assume that everything has the same
probability yes so you're kind of
assuming that every single thing was
generated well not everything has the
same probability but when you talk about
like the probability that x equals
x equals like five
I'm assuming that that's about equal to
how many times five shows up in the
so count x equals five tells me how many
times does X actually equal 5 in my data
set uh divided by the number of things
in the data set that's what I'm assuming
yeah
expectation some people call it the
weighted average yeah exactly it is
that's very correct thing to do
okay
let's jump in you guys are here we've
made so much profit progress we talked
about all the counting Theory you need
we've talked about the core probability
there's like you know seven or eight
really really important ideas that we've
talked about a lot of total probability
Bayes theorem you know a lot for you
guys to understand and now we get to
relax into the nice comfortable happy
world of random variables welcome to
this third section of class
and when we talk about random variables
I'm going to say it's nice and happy
because we get to just celebrate what
other mathematicians have had and use
their great ideas and bring it into our
tool sets and I'm going to bring you
through some of the classics we're gonna
really natural phenomena that every
person in this world should know about
and these natural phenomena that lead to
very very helpful random variables are
you guys ready
whether or not you're ready we're going
to jump in we're going to start with the
most classic random variable the number
one if I could say everybody in the
world should know this random variable
it would be this one
there's lots of stories that involve a
very common piece of probability in fact
we've seen this story before
you have n independent Trials of the
same experiment
so
at every single trial has equal
probability B of being what we call a
success
and you want to know what's the
probability of exactly K successes this
shows up all the time
we saw it very concretely in the world
of flipping a coin so imagine you're
going to flip a coin n times and you
want to know what's the probability of
getting K successes
there's very few moments in the world
where I actually care about that with
coins but there's so many things in the
world that fit this narrative you know
you have n voters and they each have a
probability P of voting for you and you
want to know what's the probability of
getting exactly K votes
and you know if you can know exactly K
votes you could do K votes K plus one
votes add up those probabilities
so many narratives fit this exact uh
formula
here's a couple examples
how many heads do you get in N coin
flips it's like n independent trials and
you want to know how many successes you
get in those
if you randomly generate a bit string of
length n and you want to know how many
ones are generated
if you have a thousand computer cluster
and you know that the computers crash
independently with some probability and
you want to know what's the probability
of different numbers of computers
crashing you can calculate that and in
fact when Computer Sciences like first
made Google and they started to First
make like large social networks they
would have their servers hosted on
thousands of computers and as the people
who really understood this natural
phenomena who are able to predict okay
when are our servers going to be
crashing and they were able to identify
uh how much extra load that they would
need to know
you know voting for a candidate we
mentioned uh quickly and we'll talk
about this later but you know if you
want to make sure that a jury is not
unfairly selected you could use this
Theory to figure out uh if things are
probabilistically out of distribution
all these stories really involve the
same key metaphor
this metaphor of I have a coin and I'm
flipping it n times it's got a p
probability being heads I want to know
how many what's the probability exactly
K heads
and we've seen that before in class and
in fact it's so important I spent a lot
of time trying to make a really cute
thing in the course reader so you can go
through it one by one and you can see
exactly why if you have 10 heads n
equals 10 heads and has a probability of
0.7
that the probability of getting exactly
six heads is going to be this beautiful
beautiful
equation down here
the probably exactly K heads in N coin
flips is going to be n choose k
P to the power of K times 1 minus P to
the power of n minus K and you don't
have to have memorized the derivation
that's kind of the point here but if
you're curious about the derivation you
should know all these steps because it's
a beautiful combination of all the core
probability we've learned so far we
talked about this earlier in class
the important takeaway today though is
what if you didn't want to rederive this
every single time you saw that metaphor
what if you just want to package all of
that work we did when we did the end
coin flips into a beautiful equation
that you could use in all other
different contexts
somebody beat you to it
and in fact back in the day somebody was
like this story of n coin flips where
the pr with the probability of coming up
heads shows up so much in different
probabilistic real world examples I want
to make a random variable around it and
I'm going to call it the binomial random
variable
huzzah
okay anyways a long story short this
person who invented this binomial random
variable that we're going to learn about
today is called Jacob Bernoulli also
known as James uh Swift mathematician uh
he's one of the many mathematicians of
the Bernoulli family uh the Bernoulli
random variables named after him even
though he is most famous for identifying
the binomial random variable
this is kind of cute I I when I was in
PhD I had an advisor that's like my
advisor and then the advisor of that
advisor Daphne color is like my great
grandmother or my grandmother and then
if you keep going there's like more and
more advisors that are in my Heritage
and he's my academic great to the 12th
grandfather which is kind of cute not
that important and I think I went with
celebrity look-alike Ice Cube but I
don't know
okay
the great thing here is if you can
recognize anything that fits this story
end coin flips probability P of success
we care about how many successes you get
you get to just write this line in your
problem set and you inherit all the
mathematics related to this story
you can say I have a random variable I'm
calling it X it is distributed as a
binomial we write bin for binomial we
don't have time to write the whole
binomial no one's got time for that bin
is enough uh and this binomial always
takes in two parameters your story is
allowed to have two pieces that you can
Define how many coin flips are there in
and what was the probability of a
success on any trial P anytime you
recognize a story you write that line
and you inherit all the mathematics
because everyone knows the mathematics
around X and if they don't know it they
should learn it because it's such a
beautiful natural phenomena
most importantly if you declare X to be
a binomial you automatically inherit
this beautiful equation and this
beautiful equation says you've told me X
is a binomial
I will tell you the probability that X
takes on the value K you don't have to
rederive it
this probability Mass function for
binomial is already known the
derivations in that multiple coin flips
question
uh it has some terms is called the
binomial term because it's the multiple
coefficient
uh and
it's just going to be this binomial term
P to the power of K one minus P to the
power of n minus K you've already told
us what p is you've already told us what
n is and when you put in K you've got
all those three values and it can give
you the probably that x equals any value
now if you go to our course reader under
random variables you'll find the
binomial distribution
and here it is and you can try different
values of N and different values of P
and as you try different values of n in
different values of P it will change the
probability Mass function that's given
for you
each of these columns can be calculated
using the pmf equation
um and but they each have their own
value this is saying if n is 23 and P is
15 the problem is getting exactly five
successes is 0.137 you can use this tool
go for it have a good time get some
intuition
okay
probability Mass function as a graph I'm
going to show you a couple this is when
n is 20 20 experiments probably 0.6 of
getting heads and this is the chance of
getting seven heads and eight heads and
nine heads isn't that just a beautiful
little curve like let's just take a
moment and appreciate the Aesthetics
ah good looking curve okay now it's not
always the same you know if you took
exactly that same n but change P to 0.1
then we get a new curve we get here's
the probability of getting zero
successes that's much more likely not
the probability of success is point one
and people can give you stories with
different ends and different P's and you
will automatically have access to this
graph
okay I got a little extreme there let's
calm down
okay
now I want to revisit this question we
talked about before we said let's say
you flip three coins
every coin comes up heads with probably
p x is the number of heads now I'm going
to Define X to be a binomial
and as soon as I Define X to be a
binomial I know these things
automatically I know that the
probability of x equals zero is just
plugging into that equation you know n
was three here K is one and P is equal
to 0.5
and if you just put those three numbers
together you get question answers for
all these we've derived these before
but you could have solved this problem
without deriving it if you just
recognize the coin flips as a binomial
expression you're done you don't have to
drive anything you just have all your
answers
okay
let's try another example
here's what a binomial question could
look like in the while it's hiding it's
lurking it's not telling you it's a
binomial distribution but if you can
recognize the biology distribution in
the world then you can solve these
problems really easily in fact the
solution just becomes for quick lines
a real world problem thousand ads are
served
every ad is clicked with a probability
of 0.01
otherwise with a probably a 0.99 people
are ignoring the ads most of us ignore
the ads come on let's be real
and then you can ask questions what's
the probability of exactly 10 clicks
and if you want to answer this question
before
you knew about binomial random variables
you'd really have to go back to
doing all of this work you would have an
answer that would be this long and you
go through all these steps but now you
know about a binomial random variable
you can answer it in four lines you say
I know H it's going to be the number of
Clips it's a random variable and it's
not just any random variable because of
the story this is the same as a thousand
coin flips each with a point zero one
probability being heads
and the question is just asking what's
the chance of 10 heads and because of
that again declare H to be a binomial
this is a powerful line
I'm saying I've seen the binomial
metaphor in this story and once you've
written this line you get this equation
for free
you know the probability that H takes on
the value of K and you get that it's
going to be a thousand choose K .01 to
the power of K and 0.99 to the power of
a thousand minus k
then if you plug 10 in for K what's the
chance of getting exactly 10 coin flips
you know exactly what that is
amazing you guys don't have to drive
things but now you have a new challenge
you have to recognize this natural
pattern in the wild
yeah questions
zeros clicks
plus probability of 10 plus
oh that's a deep question okay so far
with binomials we can just say what's
probably exactly 10 but let's expand our
abilities what if you wanted to know the
probability of exactly zero
so the probability that H equals zero
or H equals 10.
a challenge and an important challenge
that you can solve with what you've got
so far and in fact so important I'm just
going to give you guys a second think
about it talk about what the person next
to you either solve this or come up with
a question regarding what we've talked
about so far that you'd like to see
clarified anything confusing talk about
with a person next to you or try and
solve this one because it'd be nice to
be able to do more than just exactly 10
clicks eh okay go for it
okay
before we go into answers anyone come up
with a clarifying question that they
think is relevant
you're like why here's a good question
why did no one tell me about the
binomial before it's so present in so
many natural phenomena maybe you've
heard about before
if you hadn't what a beautiful day in
our lives
okay how are we going to solve this
problem H equals zero or H equals ten
you can solve it with the tools I've
given you what's the idea here
what makes probably or easy
but why can you do that you can't always
just take an or and turn it into plus
something has to be true it needs to be
expensive but are they I challenge you
on them
no no sorry sorry that was too much they
are you're absolutely right they are
mutually exclusive because it's not
possible for H to both be zero and ten
those are different numbers H is either
0 or 10 the outcome spaces are mutually
exclusive you can't have both things
happen at the same time
and because of that the probability of
or becomes easy it becomes the
probability of this times the
probability of H equals 10.
I'm going to tell you we can can answer
other questions what if you care about
the probability of less than 10 clicks
you think this is like a failed campaign
we haven't talked about less than 10
. how are you going to do that no no
think about it think about no don't talk
to your partner just think how would you
do that less than 10.
be inspired
feel the inspiration
okay hopefully you're inspired to come
up with this right you've got probably
that H equals zero or H equals one or H
equals two
or H equals nine what about ten
not less than ten man those those off by
ones are killer
and you're like each of these are
mutually exclusive you can't be zero and
one you can't be zero and two you've got
to be only one of those numbers and so
this is going to be equal to
the sum looping from x equals zero up to
and including nine the probability that
H equals X
wild okay anyways we've gotten ahead of
ourselves but I'll just leave that up
there this was the probability that h
H is less than 10.
which you might care about you oh my
gosh there's so much we can do once you
know it's a binomial random variable
Yeah question
form for B of h less than 10 no no no
this is it oh and what would you do for
H equals x I'm like why can't you just
stop there Chris
we already have the equation for that
because we declare it as a binomial you
automatically inherit this beautiful
probably Mass function which is the
probability that H takes on a particular
value and you would just plug that in
nine times question is is there a
shorter way of doing it no you must do
it nine times hopefully you have a
computer
if you have a computer nine times not a
problem in fact speaking about having a
computer I love that you guys are
computer scientists it makes teaching
this so much more reasonable because I
can tell you haha stats just gives you a
way to do this stats is a python Library
you can say from scipy import stats this
is a lot to write but you'll be very
happy because after you write
stats.binomial.pmf
it gives you this equation in Python
you have to say what is n and you have
to say what is p those are the two
parameters your binomial and then you
have to also say what is K so if you
have a thousand ads with a .01
probability of anyone clicking the
probability that exactly 10 ads are
clicked on are
it's a global thing we're not the only
ones who know about this somebody told
python uh and you could ask any question
you care about any value of n p and K
and you can get an answer so certainly
if I wanted to calculate this I would
write a simple for Loop run it 10 times
uh and I would do
stats.binomial.pmf I comma
a thousand comma 0.01 and I get the
probability that is less than 10.
oh amazing
so
I meant to just give you guys a chance
this is super important that you can do
this
now it's your turn to do I've done this
a lot but this is like the 10 out of 10
you must must be able to do this walking
out today's class 1000 ads serve
probably 0.01 of getting somebody click
on one was a probability of exactly five
clicks you have to be able to solve this
you have to be able to answer a question
like this as of now
and so if you don't good time for a
question
do do
okay
what you have to do four steps declare a
random variable I could call it h for
the number of people who click on an ad
declare H to be a binomial I would say
it has n a thousand and P 0.01 and then
I want to know what's the probability
that H equals five and you could just go
into
let's say your favorite Pisa app
now we find out if my Wi-Fi is working
um
okay nice ad Chris and you can do
n equals a thousand
P equals 0.01 whoa whoa whoa no one can
see that can you guys see that now
I could say
um
the probability
of 5 equals stats dot binom dot pmf for
probably Mass function
and 5 comma n comma p
and then in theory if I print this we'll
find out if I remembered all of those
commands off top of my head
oh
because it's not loading scipy
okay
[Music]
do you know Python's also on your
computers
python
let's run all of you guys
stats is not defined
I don't know why I didn't copy the Top
Line oh has no module called
python okay
python 3.9
I recently got python 10 and my python
10 doesn't have stats that's not
important right now
what is important is now I've run this
on my computer and it told me that zero
point
three seven is the probability that my
random variable equals five so
this is what you should feel comfortable
doing beauty of recognizing the binomial
random variable you see a question like
this and you don't have to rederive
everything you inherit the probably Mass
function it's even in scipy
okay do you guys feel like you guys
could do that in the Wild on your own
I see a bunch of nodding heads that
makes me very happy okay
um you know
you could put this into the problem set
app to see this graph and just look it
up on the graph that's one way to do it
but obviously I'll use scipy
let's try this again you guys kind of
know where I'm going but I just want to
give you this idea that it shows up in
lots of places seven runs of a program
each run crashes with probably a 0.3
what's the chance of exactly three
crashes out of your seven so maybe you
have that program that has some
intermittent bug and you're trying to
figure out will it pass the auto graders
when I submit it to cs11
seven runs a program each are
independent each crash independently
with probably 0.3 what's the chance of
exactly three crashes how would you
solve this talk about with the person
next to you while I get the board ready
okay
who here there's like a bunch of random
variables there's a binomial there's a
poisson sometimes something's not a
classic random variable you just have to
drive it from the beginning who here
thinks this is a poissa you're like
Chris you haven't taught us that not me
who serious thinks that it's like no
classic random variable we have to drive
everything from first principle I love
it who here thinks is a binomial
rocking okay so if you want to solve
this problem you just say x is defined
as a number of crashes and the next line
in your solution is X is
distributed as a binomial so this is you
declaring it's a binomial and you have
to give me two parameters n and p can
you guys just shout out what's in
wait how come it's not three
here like because that's not what it is
and is how many experiments there are
not how many successes you're looking
for
what's the probability of success in
every experiment
now this is kind of interesting we've
defined success as a crash
and in what way is crashing a program a
success
yeah
the event of a crush happening yeah it's
the event of a crash happening is what
was the thing we're trying to count uh
but anyways just it's like the heads the
head's equivalent we're thinking of
crashes being like the equivalent of
getting a heads on our coin flip
and then you define what's the question
asking the questions asking what's the
probability that x equals
three and at this point you could just
plug in the binomial distribution you
know it's seven choose three
P which is 0.3 to the power three
and 0.7 to the power of 7 minus 3 which
is four
and I know people over there might have
lost this but it's exactly what you
expect it would be
cool and you're done you could put this
into a calculator you could use the
Sci-Fi function we just showed you which
does all this in one go you now have the
ability to calculate binomials you don't
have to like if you had to redefine
derive the binomial when you saw a
question like this your midterm would be
brutal
okay
oh here's a fun one
binomials they're everywhere
so here's a Gallatin board if you guys
haven't seen a Galaxy board I actually
have one over here look really closely
now you can't see that we're going to
use the DOT cam in just a second people
who do the doc cam can you help me get
set up but just in a second don't switch
over yet but just know it's coming
a gelatin board looks like this there's
all these pins and we drop these balls
on the pins you're like what does this
have to do with probability wait for me
wait for me when the balls hit the pins
they either go left or right
and every single time they hit a pin we
think they have an equal probability of
going left and right
oh marbles whatever
every single pin is independent so what
happens on this pin doesn't change what
happens on the next pin and eventually
your ball ends up in a bucket at the
bottom
and we're not going to just drop one
marble we're going to drop a whole bunch
of marbles in fact we're going to be
dropping millions of these ones wait
they never fall out if they go all the
way to the right they end up in this
bucket
ah so I'm going to Define
R to be how many uh sorry sorry
I'm going to define B to be how many
times did you go right
and how many times can you go right
there's one two three four five chances
where you could go right or left and so
I'm going to say B is going to be the
number of times when I chose to go right
if I choose to go right zero times I'll
go left left left left I'll end up here
if I chose to go right five times so in
the first level I go right and the
second level I go right and the third
level I go right fourth level right I go
fifth level or I go right I'll end up
here
if the number of times I choose to go
right is 2 no matter where I choose to
go right twice I'll end up here so if I
go left left right
left left left right right I'll end up
here
the number of times you choose to go
right determines which bucket you end up
in and the Beautiful Thing is the number
of times that you choose to go right is
going to be binomial there's five
experiments and each experiment has a
0.5 chance of giving you a write
and you can figure out the probability
of a marble Landing in each of these
buckets using the binomial probability
Mass function the probability that a
marble goes into this bucket is the same
as a binomial with N5 P equals 0.5 being
0.
and you can calculate what that is a
0.03 you can calculate the probability
of it going to the one bucket that's
going to be 0.16 so you can do the same
thing for all the different buckets you
know exactly what this probability Mass
function is can I go to the DOT cam is
that a reasonable thing to do right now
oh yeah okay let's see if we can figure
this out though
there's this thing called a doc cam
wow what a time I'm gonna need this to
be balanced though
oh no did I press the off button
I just got it where I wanted it
oh man doc cam did I break you no you're
back you're alive
you are alive amazing
oh oh it's upside down that's hilarious
imagine if you flip this upside down so
this is just kind of like the binomial
distributions prediction of where how
many marbles would or the probably of a
marble ending up in each bucket and look
how good a prediction is oh how
beautiful okay let's do it one more time
wow that's it upside down going into I
can't flip it upside down can I
no no okay you guys we just have to get
used to looking at the world upside down
wow amazing the probability predicts it
so well yes thank you technicians we
really appreciate it all right back to
the slides
okay
here is a real one not a small one but a
really big one and they built this
somewhere and they made this huge
construction and there's this music
playing goes yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah
all your marbles are going up to the top
of your Belton Belton board all of them
are going where are they going to land
which bucket oh my gosh they're hitting
pins and the number of Rights they take
binomial distribution all of them going
go go go
and through all of this chaos
such predictable order
it comes is it going to follow the
distribution that the binomial predicts
yes again is it going to do it this time
I don't know does probability lie
sometimes people lie with probability
but this time the probability is right
it goes It goes It goes you get the
bridal distribution oh my gosh from
chaos you get such order
wait I'll that's actually the next
example uh
it is such a beautiful thing in this
world
that from all of this uncertainty that
you get such incredible order and it's a
natural phenomena you now know what to
call it is the binomial distribution and
it shows up in lots of other places for
example what's binomial distribution
doing in my basketball game let me tell
you if you don't know this when people
get to the playoffs in the basket in
basketball they play seven game series
and in those seven game series if you
win four of those games you have just
won the series and so often people care
not about the probability of just
winning one game but what's the
probability of winning a seven game
series so out of those seven games you
play what's the probability of winning
four or more
my claim for you is that if you wanted
to drive this from first principle it
would be very very hard you would have
to kind of go back to the whole coin
flipping derivation
but if you can see the binomial here
your life is a lot easier so take a
moment look at this question can you see
the binomial so the Warriors are playing
the Bucks and the best of seven series
sorry this is before I knew who they
actually play uh they won how crazy is
that wow it's our local basketball team
yay okay
um
what's the probability of winning at
least four games
and see the binomial
it's seven coin flips
and a head is a win
so X my random variable I'm going to be
finding to the be the number of wins in
my seven point flips and as soon as I do
that my next step is to let the whole
world that X is binomial the number of
coin flips is seven
the probability of a heads on each coin
flip is a 0.55
but that just tells me the whole
distribution for what's the chance that
they win zero of those games what's the
chance that they win one of those games
what's the chance that they win two or
three four games means that they win the
series five games also means to win the
series six games win the series and
seven games also means that they win the
series
somebody's like wait
don't they stop playing if they win four
like they don't bother with the next
three like if they win win win win win
no one plays those other three in my
world they do play those other three uh
and it doesn't change the outcome of
this probability experiment
thank you
that'd be kind of fun
but tiring for the players and maybe
they get injured and then we'd be sad
okay I'm glad that they do it the way
they do it uh and this will allow us to
solve the problem of the probability
that they win at least four
the question is asking what's the
probability X greater than or equal to
four
and we don't have an equation for that
we only have the probability that X is
equal to four
but for those of you guys who've been
paying attention to Mutual exclusivity
you know that this is the same as saying
what's the probability that x equals 4
plus the probability that x equals five
plus the probability that x equals six
plus the probability that x equals 7.
every single one of these equations is
given to you by the probability Mass
function
you can ask what's the probability that
binomial with N7 T 0.55 equals four and
you can ask it for five and six and
seven since they're mutually exclusive
we can add them up and this would be the
probability that they win the series
so just to put that into the slides
what I'm saying is Define a binomial
with seven games and 0.55 and the
probability Mass function will tell you
what's the probability of zero wins out
of seven not very likely they're quite
good one two and three and what I'm
saying is we're going to add the
probability mass of four with a probably
mass of five with a probably a mass of
six and the probability mass of seven
that's what adding up each of these
things is doing it's looking up each of
the columns and adding them together
if you did that you could write it as a
for Loop and a for Loop in math looks
just like this and everything in the for
Loop you know we're plugging in the
binomial distribution probably Mass
function I is the index of my for Loop
and it shows up in this probably Mass
function where K would normally show up
in the pmf
and if you put this into
uh
into something like
PSI pi and since I
uh what we could do is we could say for
I
in range
four to seven or four to eight I think
if you do this you get
four five six seven yeah for Iron Range
four to eight
we're going to just oh I need to get a
sum
for I in range zero to eight some
probability plus equals
stats dot binomial dot probably Mass
function
I because that's
the number of wins we're looking for
there are seven games and each one has a
0.55 probability
so this is going to Loop four times and
I will take on the value 4 5 6 7 and
each time we'll say what's probably
exactly I wins add those all together
and we have some probability
and the chance of them winning at least
four games is 61.
so even though it's pretty even chance
for any one game the chance that they
win the whole series is pretty large
I'll just make that quite big because
going from math
understanding to code understanding I
think is something that you probably
wouldn't have seen in other classes and
I think it's very important if you want
to start making Tools around this cool
theory that we're learning this is like
Theory to practice in one in one screen
question
yeah yes uh is it possible for a random
variable to take on multiple different
values
no it's always mutually exclusive
because we think of it if it takes on
One value it just can't be another one
if they won four games they can't have
one six games because we think equals
two as being just that value such a good
question so always mutually exclusive
can always use the sum trick yes
if they had to stop playing afterwards
well they do and this is still the right
answer even though they stop I'm so glad
you asked that because
it's such a common problem when people
do probability to get tripped up by the
fact that they stop at four games in the
real world that I want to take a moment
and talk about this I've seen so many
students make this bug can we just talk
about it together
here's how people make this bug
you want to know what's the probability
of at least K successes in N independent
trials
X is going to be the number of successes
in end trials with probability of K so X
is our binomial random variable
some people say what's the problem that
X is greater than or equal to K they
don't use the fact that it's a binomial
random variable or they just think of it
like this
I want to choose case slots for my
successes
and then I'm going to say in those case
successes you know each one has a
probability P of being a success
right
and there's K of my successes so you
choose your case successes you choose
where they go and for the other ones
they could be successes are not
successes
if they're not successes in the other
slots then
you still have exactly at least K
successes because we've chosen K of them
to be successes
you know if they end up being success is
great we had more than K successes that
also fits this definition does this seem
like a pretty reasonable thing to do
you know
K successes each have probably P you can
choose where they go
turns out this is not the way to solve
this you still need to use this sum from
k equal I equals K to n and the binomial
probability of your random variable
equally exactly I
and a good way to show that this is a
bug is to First think about
what happens if the probability is one
so if your probability is one let's go
back to this equation
you have one times itself K times that's
going to be one right
but n choose K is going to be something
greater than 1.
and this is going to say that the
probability that X is greater than K is
going to be a number greater than one
and it turns out that doesn't work you
can't have a probability that's greater
than one so if it turns if this case
fails then there must be something wrong
uh with this outcome
the reason we have this n choose K in
this binomial distribution probably Mass
function is because each of those
outcomes of heads and tails were
mutually exclusive you know if you had
tails heads Heads Tails let's say
there's four trials and you're looking
for two heads
heads Tails heads Tails each of these
outcomes were mutually exclusive
there is n choose K of them
but because they're Mutual exclusive we
could add the probably this row with the
probably of this row and every single
row ended up having P to the K times 1
minus P to the N minus K so that's why
we could if you add it up P to the K
times P to the 1 minus K and choose K
times the same as multiplying entries K
by the probability of n one row so it
relied on the fact that these rows were
mutually exclusive in this derivation
you have rows where you have like the
heads are defined
and you have blanks
where there's no heads
and you're saying I'm going to add up
all the rows the probability of every
row is just the probability of the heads
and I'm going to not care about what
shows up in these other slots but it
turns out you could end up with let's
say we put a head here and a tail here
with some choices for these other slots
you end up with non-mutually exclusive
rows which means you can't use this n
choose K multiplier that we used in our
binomial distribution
okay
um
I think that answers one bug but I
believe your question was slightly
different
your question was what happens if they
stop after four games
so
let's think about
the case where the Warriors have won
four games the first four games
you have heads heads heads heads
and I've what I've done is there's three
more games and I've got every
combination of like heads Tails heads
here you go see heads heads heads Heads
Tails Tails Tails heads heads heads
every two to the three ways shows up
here
my claim for you
is that if you added up all of these
probabilities
that that is the same as the probability
of just heads heads heads
on its own
and there's a bit of a law of total
probability thing going on here you know
like these background contexts don't
matter and I'm looping over every single
possibility and adding them together and
so by a lot of probability argument
these things end up being equivalent to
the probability of heads heads heads
Heads not worrying about the other four
that is a very complicated argument but
um
it you know if we thought about this not
mathematically but intuitively I'm
saying you know all these cases are
going to exist
but when these ones exist what you'll
experience in the real world is just
they stop playing
and even though I've thought about the
futures of the what would happen if they
did play in the real world You observe
them stop playing but it doesn't change
the fact that this derivation uh to do
that I have over here
is the correct one so thinking about
seven trials and the probability of
getting I successes out of those seven
trials yeah
which means our n 20.7 right yeah but in
my thing I treat it as seven and it just
made this case happily work out
if you wanted to just think about this
case on its own
I guess you could say
okay if you wanted to drive this with n
of four
you would say in four experiments what's
the probability of getting exactly four
successes
and then in five experiments what's it
probably getting exactly four successes
no that's problematic because they're
not mutually exclusive
um
but um
so my derivation I always play out all
seven games I always set n equals seven
and P equals
0.055 which means I'm always making the
Warriors play even though these are
ghost games and in reality they wouldn't
play them and the reason that this
doesn't affect it like the fact that
they're ghost games versus not Ghost
Games doesn't affect the probability
that this will give you the chance that
they win
okay
good questions
big picture now if you can recognize a
binomial distribution in the real world
you get so much for free you get all of
these things that you get in the course
reader for free
um you get the PMS equation you get that
the expectation is just equal to n times
p and you get a little bit more
we're going to talk about that a little
bit more after our pedagogical pause so
I'll give people two minutes to just
take a break solidify and crystallize
what we've learned so far before we walk
into our next piece of today's class
okay
fantastic that was such a good question
about the hey they don't actually play
seven games they sometimes stop after
four why does that not matter and I feel
like that's best explained by just kind
of enumerating over a whole bunch of
possibilities so we're going to write
that up for people curious about that
detail and we'll make an End post for
you guys
okay
as we last left off we learned about the
binomial distribution one of the most
beautiful natural distributions in the
world you can use it anytime you
recognize it you'll start recognizing a
lot in the world but let's go back to
Jacob Bernoulli he's like I invented one
of the most useful random variables in
the world and they didn't call the newly
random variable he's like sad face
Bernoulli uh and he's like can I have a
variable named after myself and people
in fact were like okay you can have one
and they kind of gave him the most
boring random variable to be honest uh
he gave him the special case of the
binomial where n is equal to one
if n is equal to 1 what are the
different values that your random
variable could take on if x is the
number of successes in one coin flip
it can be a zero or a one which is kind
of cool he kind of gets the
probabilistic equivalent of a bit
um but anyways yeah he gets his the
Bernoulli random variable is named after
him special case of the binomial if you
declare X to be a Bernoulli random
variable it will take on the value one
with probability P you have to say
what's the probability of heads and it's
going to be a zero with probably of one
minus p
if you find something that is basically
a single coin flip and you're measuring
number of heads on a single coin flip
which doesn't happen all that often but
you know it's very important to give you
this terminology because it does show up
again in machine learning literature a
lot you define X to be a Bernoulli
random variable and you say x is a
Bernoulli uh with probability P probably
of success
the expectation of this random variable
it turns out is equal to exactly is p
and here's a couple examples you flip a
single coin and you want to know number
of heads you get a random binary digit
and you want to know whether or not it's
a one and you want to know the outcome
of it whether a single dish dive crashes
and whether somebody likes a single
Netflix movie it's a special case of a
nearly random variable
I'm not gonna go too much into it
because I think a lot of this is pretty
self-evident
um you can just Define if something says
like I serve a single ad and people
click with a probably p and they ignore
it with probably one mysp C is going to
be a one if the ad is clicked you can
declare C to be a Bernoulli and it
doesn't buy you that much the binomial
buys you so much and the Bernoulli
really just doesn't buy you that much uh
and you can think of the though as if a
Bernoulli is a zero or one
you can think about the binomial as
being a sum of bernoullis and that's
actually quite helpful so you can
imagine if this is this Bernoulli is
going to be like there's four coin flips
and this Bernoulli represents whether
the first coin flip was ahead it'll be a
zero one
this particularly represents where the
second coin flips the heads it'll be a
zero one this third Bernoulli represents
how many coin flips our heads in that
third coin flip it will be a zero one is
how many coins are heads in the fourth
coin flip it'll be zero one you can
think of the binomial of four coin flips
as the sum of each of those bernoullis
it's gonna be the sum of those zero Z
ones zero if it's Tails one if it's a
heads you add all those up and you get
your number of successes
okay and I'm going to give you a reason
to have learned the Bernoulli
we're going to use the fact that we now
have a Bernoulli to come up with a
simple derivation for the expectation of
binomial I told you the expectation of
binomial random variable is just n times
P now I'm going to drive it for you
so X is going to be our binomial
but we know that X is just going to be
the sum of a bunch of underlying
Bernoulli's so x i is going to be a 1 if
the ith coin flip is a heads and it'll
be a zero if the ith coin flip is a
tailed and if you sum up all those zeros
and ones and there's n of them you'll
get the number of coin flips
this is the very first time we've really
seen a random variable defined as being
the sum of other random variables
you add up all these zeros and ones and
you get X which is the number of
successes
and that's quite interesting because if
you want to do expectation of X you can
now replace x with that sum you can say
this is really the expectation of the
sum
one of the properties that I reminded
you guys of at the beginning of this
class is the expectation of the sum is a
sum of expectations another way of
thinking about that is expectation
always has the keys to the house like
look at this beautiful house
expectations like hey house I just want
to get in there and like as soon as
expectations on the outside of the house
is like hi guys I'm inside because the
expectation of sum is the sum of
expectations
what's the expectation of a single coin
flip
a single coin flip which has a
probability of P of being heads well
let's think about it let's say the
expectation of y i
why I can take on two values we're going
to take each of those values and
multiply them by the probabilities one
value that y I can take on is zero you
can get zero coin flips in your I coin
flip zero heads in your ice coin flip
what's the probability of getting zero
coin flips doesn't matter it's
multiplied by zero
what's the other outcome of the ice coin
flip
yeah one
these bernoullis separate from binomials
special case they can only take on value
zero and one and what's the probability
of getting one heads in a single coin
flip
P yeah p is the probability of getting a
heads so this whole expectation of y i
is just equal to P there's zero times
whatever one minus p goes away
because explanation of y i is equal to P
we can just substitute it in there and
this is going to say the sum from 1 to n
of p is going to be the expectation of
your binomial
so the expectation of binomial is n
times p
very hard to derive if you didn't use
the fact that the binomial is actually
the sum of these bernoullis so even
though the Bernoulli is just really not
that interesting of a random variable
sometimes it shows up in proofs like
this
and also you just kind of need to know
it if you want to be like a a
conversational probabilist in the world
so anyway we have this binomial what a
beautiful curve and then you have the
Bernoulli it's like I'm zero or one and
I'm one with p and I'm zero with one
minus P deal with it but anyways it's a
random variable too and it's a class of
random variables you can declare things
to be bernoullis
okay
so here we are we will continue to grow
our understanding of natural phenomena
and classical ideas of random variables
but before we go any further
we need to talk about other things we
can do with random variables one thing
we know we can do with random variables
you could summarize it into a single
number expectation
but expectation is a very lacking number
what if we want to add a second number
so we could summarize the random
variable a little bit more holistically
expectation leaves so much to be desired
in fact a lot of people who lie with
Statistics are lying with expectations
and my question for you is I want you
guys to invent another summary statistic
to go beyond expectation and we're going
to start with a story of peer grading so
we're going to think about somebody who
is being peer graded by other people and
they want to get the grade that they
deserve
imagine three different graders you have
greater a if this is the true grade that
somebody deserves this is the
distribution of grades that greater a
gives
sometimes they give the grade that this
deserved but sometimes they give a grade
that's way lower and sometimes give the
greatest way higher
here's greater B
and here's greater C
I want to find out if we can tell a
story of who we want to be grading us
and figure out what we would like to
measure in order to talk about greater
accuracy
now think about this for a second do you
want greater a b or c grading U
the red lines the grade you deserve and
this distribution is the grade that
they're giving you so C is kind of a
jerk if you're like I deserved a 70 it's
like 50. I'm like but I deserved a 70.
so I think a lot of us would be like
okay see if it was the other way around
they were giving us grades higher than
we deserve we'd take them
but because they're giving us lower
grades we don't want it
A and B have exactly the same
expectation
in expectation they give you the exact
same grade
but who wants to be graded by person a
and who wants to be graded by person B
there's not a wrong answer here you're
like actually b means you're getting the
grade you deserve and a is like they're
throwing a dart at the dartboard and
adding it to the grade you deserve and
like maybe you're getting a 40 or maybe
you're getting a hundred and some people
just like live on the edge like that uh
but what if we had to put in words
what's the difference between a and b
it's not expectation in expectation
they're exactly the same
now I don't want that and worried I want
another term for it
bread
spread is a nice natural term there's a
lot of spread here and there's a little
spread here and it'd be nice if we could
come up with a quantification of spread
I'm going to give you a slightly simpler
example where you can go into exact
numbers here are three distributions
with the same exact expectation they all
have expectation of three
but the difference between these three
distribution is how much spread that
they have you know this has a ton of
spread and this has very little spread I
want you guys to invent what would be a
good definition for spread
so
how can we Define spread and I'm going
to give you guys a second to think about
it talk about with the person next to
you I'm going to give you three whole
minutes to think about how would you
quantify spread
and to make it easy you could think
about this as being like 10 000 unique
numbers and this is just the histogram
of those 10 000 unique numbers that
might make it easier to think about
quantifying spread
okay let's get ideas let's throw them on
the board
how can we do it
and I don't know if it's helpful but I
imagine you know we have a whole
distribution and I want us to think
about two pieces of this distribution
here's a chunk of the probability that's
a certain distance from below the
expectation and here's a chunk of
probably that's a certain distance above
the expectation how can we quantify this
spread
looking for maybe somebody who hasn't
said something today
yes well you can start by taking the
distance from each data point to the
expectation okay let's talk about the
distance
to the expectation
like that because you know when there's
High spread you have these things that
are really far away from the expectation
when there's low spread you have things
that are really close so distance seems
like a very good idea there's lots of
ways you can measure distance
let me give you a bad one
you could take the value
and you could just subtract off the
expectation
and we can say we just want the average
of all those you know give me the
average of the value itself minus the
expectation so like over here this would
be like a positive 5 and this would be a
minus five
why is that a bad way to measure
distance
yeah it's like these positive ones will
lead to a large value and these negative
ones will lead to a negative value but
if you take the average of these
positive and negative they'll cancel out
so what's a better way of calculating
distance than just taking the value and
subtracting off the expectation
oh okay I've heard two two good ideas
you can take the absolute value
so you take the distance you subtract
off see how far it is away from the
expectation and if it's negative you
make it positive
and then if you take the average of that
over all of your distribution
that would work
and somebody else said
don't do that I want to do the average
of the squared distance so take the
difference between X and its expectation
Square it and I kind of want to average
that over my whole distribution
and expectation is my function for
averaging over the whole distribution
which one is right
both right
they're both right
if we had gone back in time and we were
inventing variance we could have made
either of these the definition of
variance and they both would have been
reasonable
people happen to have chosen this one so
I think this one would have made
absolutely good sense to get the Pun
It's absolute
okay question
um different skills that use different
definitions of like just kind of so like
sometimes things prefer absolute values
and something for first wearing there's
times when people when you're thinking
about distances in lots of fields like
when you get into machine learning
there's lots of times people think about
distances uh and people call this the L1
Norm people call this the L2 norm and
there's times when you might care about
these different distances there's even
other ones Beyond these two and people
have argued about them in lots of
different fields
and in probability they just happen to
have chosen this one and I think every
time people talk about variants I've
seen them talk about it in terms of this
distance measure yes
it punishes
stuff that's further or further away
which seems worse yeah you're right it
does punish things so like if you get
really really big differences between
the expectation and your value when you
square it it's going to look really
really bad whereas if you get small
numbers and you square it's not so bad
so it does have that property whereas
the absolute value one doesn't punish
being too far away as harshly so they do
have this qualitative difference and
that's a really nice maybe that's a good
reason for choosing the L2 Norm
anyways long story short people derive
Define this thing this measure of spread
that people call variance and they
Define it to be over your whole
distribution
on average what is the distance of
values to the expectation I'm going to
use this shorthand form for the
expectation of X mu because otherwise
you have too many expectations of x's
there
and just to give you an idea of what's
going on here if you had a data set and
you had to calculate this let's say x
here is 25
x minus the expectation so 25 minus 60
will be a negative number why don't you
square it it will be a large positive
number and you could keep doing this for
every single data point in your data set
if either you Loop over your whole data
set or you take every data point and
weight it by its probability you would
get the average of the distances of
every point in this distribution to its
mean and you could calculate for this
you could say it's 52 points squared
that's the units what's a point squared
I don't know that's just what the units
are
um and well it turns out a lot of times
people are like I don't like these
points squared so there's this other
definition of spread standard deviation
which is just the square root of the
expectation
is just taking this number Square
rooting it that's the standard deviation
um
so
variance it's defined to be
the expectation of the distance from
points in your distribution with its
mean of the distribution and distance is
measured by taking the difference
squared
it's a formal definition of spread it
has other names somebody asked earlier
in class what if you have other moments
well it turns out variance is the second
moment expectations the First Central
moment variance is the second Central
moment you can imagine that there's
moments Beyond this we're going to stop
at variance in cs109
okay
um this is an idea normalized histograms
are approximations are probably Mass
function we'll talk about that more
another day
I did want to talk about how you compute
this in the real world
that is the definition we really cared
about
we really cared about having the average
of the distance from the mean
now
earlier in class I told you there's this
law of unconscious statistician and the
law of unconscious statistician says if
you apply any function to an expectation
like if you want to know the expectation
of any function of your random variable
that this is equal to the sum of all the
values just apply the function to each
of those values and then multiply it by
its probability
that was the law of unconscious
statistician and this is the very first
time we're going to use it I want to
come up with an easier way to calculate
variance
our function here is take X subtract off
its mean and square it that's a function
and so we can use the law of unconscious
statistician and it's going to enroll
expectation like this it's just going to
apply that exact same function to every
single value
so every single value you're going to
subtract off the mean and square it and
you're going to do that before you
multiply that probably that x equals X
if you started to apply this law of
unconscious statistician you can take
this expression and just do a little bit
of algebra which I'll leave for you guys
to do at home if you're curious but you
can just expand this term kind of
regroup it into different parts
take those groupings and simplify them
again
and you end up with well at this point
you enter this expectation of x squared
which we'll talk about in a second
um leave that in there and if you just
simplify this like this is the mean
times expectation well expectation is
what we defined the mean to be and this
thing just simplifies till eventually
you get that if you want to calculate
variance
you could calculate this equation that's
semantically what we care about but we
can derive that there's this equivalent
way of calculating variance
and this is the one that's so much
easier to do
and this calculations looks crazy it
looks like you have the same thing
multiplied or subtracted from itself you
have expectation of x squared
and you're subtracting that from
expectation wait for it
x squared
and that's the equivalent of that and
that feels like it should be zero but
it's not zero this is the expectation of
x
and this is the expectation of applying
the squared function to X if we use the
law of unconscious statistician we can
know what the expectation of x squared
is the expectation of x squared
well
is going to be equal to using the law of
unconscious statistician
expectation
of x squared
is going to be the sum over all the
values that X can take on Square that
value before you multiply by the
probably that x equals x that's what the
expectation of x squared is it's
different from taking expectation of X
and then squaring it
here yeah
yeah so I guess you're just wearing the
efficient and the X in this case yeah
here you're taking each of the values
and squaring it when you're weighting it
into the expect into the sum
and in the other term you're calculating
the normal expectation and then squaring
it afterwards and it turns out it really
does matter whether or not you square
each value versus whether if you take
the expectation squared and this thing
is called the second moment it's just a
funny name for something that we use in
our calculation of variance
and it really comes down to this if
somebody asks you to calculate variance
you're going to use that equation
okay we are at the end of today's day
and you know the big takeaway is we've
defined variance we now Define it to be
this thing and you can now standard
deviations defined to be the square root
of variance
we'll pick up this conversation on
Wednesday thank you guys so much for
such a fun Class come back on Wednesday
we'll continue this conversation of
random variables you'll learn about the
poisson one of my second favorite random
variables of all time have a great day
come back on Wednesday see you later
cs109